[Music]
foreign
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we help people
build wealth do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Dr John baloney Ramsey
personality number one best-selling
author and host of the very popular
Ramsey networks produced Dr John deloney
show where we deal with all kinds of
relationship and mental health issues
he's my co-host today as we're taking
your questions phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
this is where Common Sense meets reality
and life and it does it every day here
thanks for joining us the call is free
and some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it Elizabeth is with us
in Dallas hi Elizabeth welcome to the
Ramsay show
hello how are you great what's up
hi so I have a question I've been with
my partner boyfriend for seven years and
we have two small children together and
I've recently brought up the fact that
we should get married and actually have
one bank account and do everything
together and he says that he doesn't
want to do that but marriage is not why
he doesn't want to do marriage and he
says because he's already previously
been married and he's just not he's just
not going to do it why does he think
he's not married now
I'm not sure he's got all he's got
everything he had to do with marriage
right now
so now my next question he gets sick he
gets sick he wants you to make him
chicken soup right
yes yeah what's the difference in this
in marriage I'm confused well
he's not interested that either accept
him or or what shall we do
so Elizabeth I want you to hear what
he's actually telling you
he's telling you he went all in on
somebody once and got hurt or broke up
with or whatever
and he's looking at you after seven
years and two children and saying you're
not worth that
I'd rather
um have my illusion of singleness in my
back pocket at all times
so that I can preserve my little fragile
ego meanwhile Playhouse and play house
with you and you be my wife and I'll
keep all the equity and everything and
I'll keep all my money and I'll
basically pay you like a live-in nanny
um but this is all mine
that's what he's telling you
I hate that for you I'm sorry I hate
that for you
how old are your babies
one is four and the other is one little
boy little girl what
um it's a one
to four year old girl
so at this point I'm at the point that I
don't know what to do I don't know if 20
years from now your daughter is 24 and
she asks you this question what do you
tell her
I don't know hmm
I'm not gonna I I'm not gonna be the
person that tells you you got to stay or
leave
because I don't want I don't want you to
hang on to this guy said this that's
something that's a decision you're gonna
have to own
what I will tell you is I think you are
worth going all in on
and I think you're worth having a home
that two people want to do life together
and create a safe space to raise these
two beautiful little babies
you're worth that
you're gonna have to make the grown-up
decision whether you stay and you try to
build a life inside of a cocoon or
you make other decisions
in two weeks I'll be in two weeks I'll
be go ahead I'm sorry go ahead babe what
um I'm mostly more afraid if like if I
walk away how would I manage with money
I haven't worked in a while
so that's
I'm gonna be truthful that's exactly
what's stopping me now from walking away
and that's a very real fear I mean
that's a very real fear the the data
suggests that when men and women split
up especially in this situation his net
worth will actually go up and yours will
go down for a season
until you get so pissed off that you
become a multi-millionaire later but
yeah
um
but yeah the uh uh so in other words you
can't do this today it's Theory
because you got babies you have to feed
but you can say all right I'm gonna plan
my Escape
and I'm gonna get my career tooled up
and I'm gonna go get a job and I'm gonna
start making some serious money and then
I get to make decisions from strength
rather than from weakness
get to walk to something not run from
something
and then you can walk in and go uh not
sure dude that I want to marry you so
there's that
and that's what we call an Elizabeth
burn right when you flip the whole thing
around
mic drop yeah but that comes from
strength and you're you're
um
when you're scared and broke it keeps
you from making decisions so let's move
from scared and broke and then remake
the decision you might make the decision
under strength to stay but you would
need to make it from strength rather
than from weakness is that logical
so if it takes you a year to start
making forty thousand dollars a year
then take that year and go do it that's
fine I got no plan got no problem
he ain't going nowhere yeah and you're
in Dallas man there will be people that
will hire you in about 20 seconds
I don't want my kids in daycare then
marry their mother hey Elizabeth it's
not uncommon in this situation
especially after this long
that this isn't the only thing that this
person won't quote unquote do
this person's been telling you that your
things you think are funny or stupid and
the feelings or concerns you have about
any number of things are dumb
you can't fill in the blank and after
seven years after almost a decade of
this you've come to believe that stuff
to be true right
yeah
yeah I don't I don't either
because the girl that called here has
got more stuff inside of her then she
sounds like she does or thinks she does
now go get it
get you some
thank you yeah really I mean don't
forget two old guys believe in you yeah
and and uh and you got a four-year-old
daughter watching to see how mama is a
Warrior Princess
look out here comes Xena
you remember that one yeah but don't
make that little weird noise call thing
keep that one to yourself Elizabeth
don't do that let that only be in your
head yeah don't don't do that yeah but
yeah you bring that up it's a there's a
concern obviously which is financial
which is real that's math there is no
debate about that and
what about my babies and what you bring
up is really important there is a
ringside seat to oh this is what a mom
and a wife are supposed to just accept
is reality or I had a ringside seat to
watching my mom go from a a live-in
boyfriend that told her dude I'm not
wasting any more energy on you all the
way to a successful business owner
Warrior Princess Running Shop and they
got to watch that happen in real time
yeah some of the most uh powerful people
I've met a single mom raised them oh man
and she was a go-getter and she wouldn't
be denied yeah and uh yeah if the kids
take that work ethic and then they go
become a surgeon or something and
there's no stop
it sets up the Next Generation you're
setting up the Next Generation so spend
the next year deciding that and getting
ready
sorry you're facing this kiddo this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a five
thousand dollar seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from
Churchill gives you an advantage over
those other guys go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
foreign
two years of broadcasting experience and
go with my gut on something here I want
to continue that conversation
um from that last caller yeah the uh
Because the actual data is and those of
you that are old like me you don't
realize this data but more people now
live together
than are married okay
statistic I mean the actual human beings
are more more shacking up cohabitating
whatever you want to call it than are
married
and
what people don't grasp is the data it's
been going on it's been going on since
the you know the The Love Shack of the
70s and from then on you know here we go
and uh so
what people don't realize is the um
unintended consequences legally
financially
uh relationally that builds up in these
situations there's
books of research on this now on the
actual results and in the financial
Arena as an example we'll start with
that one the there is a thing called the
marriage advantage
you've seen this data and the marriage
Advantage says that married people live
longer
I think that's because your wife drives
you crazy to go get a physical but I
don't know exactly what it is but
married people live longer and their net
worth is significant and their net worth
is significantly larger and their
incomes and their career trajectory is
significantly higher statistically so
that's not like a Dave opinion so you
little farts on Tic Tac can just go run
off the cliff all right but the the it
with your little comments but the facts
are the data says that your net worth
your longevity and your uh uh uh career
track and income all are improved with
marriage it's called the the research
piece the buckets of research are called
the marriage advantage in general
there's a whole volume also if you live
together prior to getting married
you are statistically four times more
likely to get a divorce later
I hadn't heard it being that high wow
that's wild you know and so you get and
there's all kinds of other things that
come in with the cohabitating Pro or I'm
going to try on these shoes to make sure
they fit before we buy them you know
kind of a thing right and so
um there's all kinds of data that shows
the disadvantages to that there's all
kinds of data that shows a disadvantages
to short engagements you get you know
you meet someone this weekend and by
next weekend you're married
statistically you're very unlikely for
that marriage to last as compared to
someone who has a six-month engagement
period average not a two year or a six
year but a six-month engagement period
average after the dating process has
begun because it takes a little while to
figure out is this a person I want to
spend the rest of my life with duh met
them at a bar on Saturday married on
Monday that's Las Vegas that's not smart
okay and so um it just does it can it
can it work does it work occasionally
sure sure there's always statistical
anomalies but I'm talking about if
you're if you're 16 or you have a 16
year old what would you tell them the
best way for them to have their most
prosperous quality life is
have four or five Long Island Iced Teas
put all your money on red and find
somebody to marry before the weekend's
over right no one would say that no
would say that right no grandmother ever
told her her granddaughter that right
good grief no yeah
um just saddle up at the daiquiri bar
and see how this works
if you marry somebody with a daiquiri
bar I'm just gonna go ahead and say that
study's probably not been done that
ain't gonna last Ain't Gonna Last that's
a John deloney study yes all right but
here's the other I don't know that this
study's been done and I don't know that
it needs to be
that last caller said something that's
important in this it's this illusion of
freedom and singleness
I'm gonna live with somebody for two
years five years seven years I'm gonna
have kids with them but I'm not gonna
get married
because I want to keep that Shard right
at the door one foot out the door and
what you forget is
he or she can't fully anchor into you
those kids can't fully anchor into this
unit
um
because it's not fully a unit yet
because you got one foot out of the boat
you only Row in one hit one armed right
yeah it's so hard it's impossible and
it's put her in a position almost as if
she was in a domestic violence situation
she'd not I don't think but um but but
she's trapped and that's the the abuser
uses the trapped oh you how you're going
to live you ain't gain money you know so
they're trapped so they stay in the
punching bag scenario because that's the
only way the kids get to eat but also
guess what the kids get to watch this
and so they think that's how it's done
and this is a problem yeah it's a
serious problem so just telling you I
mean what would you tell
your
seven-year-old daughter right your your
17 year old daughter your 17 year old
son what is a man look like in these
situations well you know a a reasonable
length of Engagement
um not living together prior to marriage
and then getting married you have the oh
by the way if you graduate from college
you know you heard this thing 50 of the
marriages fail you heard that one yeah
it's absolutely not true that's right
absolutely not true they don't
okay if you make more than fifty
thousand dollars a year household income
both of you graduate from college and
both of your parents are still married
you have a 90 chance of your marriage
lasting
that's the stats that's the real stats
okay so this then some of these are you
can't control whether your parents are
still together but you can control
graduating from school you can control
accomplishing goals you can control
delaying pleasure called maturity you
can control these things these are
controllables that you can use to set
the table for your life
and then you get to see what the results
are what the what the fruit is out of
that and so you know so you know none of
my children prior to marriage live
together none of them it wasn't because
Dad's a big old meaning no it's because
autonomous stuff Tom you have a distinct
advantage
if you will have a reasonable length of
Engagement
graduate from school make a reasonable
income marry someone that is of the same
religious preference that you are learn
to set boundaries with extended family
if you do all of these things it's and
agree on kids how many to have and
whether let them live all these kinds of
things right and that was a joke and um
sort of you know the the um but I mean
when you have these things lined up
ahead of time your probability of having
a a marriage that lasts is very high I
mean sure and I'm getting ready to
celebrate 41 years and there have been
times we almost killed each other but
you fell back on that Covenant well and
we fell back on this value system that
set us up to win I mean it's just
ridiculous I always like to flip the
coin and ask myself what is it what has
happened in this many years and
for people to opt out and I I do want to
put some of the ownership on those of us
who are married with kids
if
you make marriage appear to be miserable
and you scream and you fight and you
it's abusive and somebody's always
leaving or coming or going
what kid in their right mind would look
and go I want to opt into that and so I
feel an extra responsibility to model
for my kids here's what love looks like
here's what coming back together after
disagreement uh here's what the repairs
they call it here's that looks like
here's what's saying I'm sorry looks
like here's what's asking for
forgiveness looks like I want to model
this is the best way to to create a
world going forward and if you didn't
have that and you're entering into
marriage you need to get some people in
your life that you see do have 40 years
50 years ahead of you and they can give
you some wisdom along the way but
there's something about man this doesn't
have to be the old ball and chain as the
old songs go this could be the greatest
thing that ever happened to you if you
opt into it and you live into it that
way
well and all the data that I'm just
saying indicates that right is it
perfect no no that hillbilly woman I
about killed each other a couple times I
mean you know I'm just saying it's not
perfect I've always set fire to my
marriage
yeah multiples but that doesn't mean
that we weren't dialed in and going
right what do I want when I'm old really
old I'm old now but I mean really what
do I want then that's real you know
that's real older than me that's really
up this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
hallow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling Hollow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hollow.com Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America we're
glad you're here
hey we have folks who tune in to every
single episode of the Ramsey Show they
know all the answers but they're still
stressed
and stuck
because knowing what you do with your
money isn't the problem doing it
is the answer
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's
only 20 head knowledge and The Proven
way to change your behavior
is by taking Financial Peace University
10 million people have this class is the
difference between trying to get in
shape on your own versus hiring a
personal trainer
you'll have a coordinator who loves you
enough to hold you accountable and
encourage you they're superheroes
and the other people in the class will
be cheering you on this is why this
class has worked for so many millions of
people after nine weeks you will never
handle money the same way again
I can get that information for free off
of YouTube you can get it before we put
it on YouTube it was called common sense
but you weren't doing it then either
so when you go through the class it's
actually boot camp you're actually going
to do it it's no longer it's game on
game on baby
break the huddle
let's play
join a join a Financial Peace University
class at ramsaysolutions.com FPU
ramseysolutions.com
FPU Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host today Ann is in
Albuquerque New Mexico hi Anne welcome
to the Ramsay show
thanks for having me sure what's up
I have a question
um so I
background I make 110 a year
I've paid off thirty six thousand
dollars in the last 18 months
um it's been hard since I've done it way
to go yeah yeah
um but my goal was to to be done by
October of this coming year and I owe 17
000 on my car I have 17 000 in an air
conditioner loan and 14 000 in a student
loan
um and I really want those student loans
gone before they kick back in I've been
chipping away at it but I really just
want it done so I have an offer on my
car
um for 33 000 and that would get me out
of my my car loan and that would get me
out of the student loans and it would
just leave me with the air conditioners
um but it would also leave me with no
car I do have a teenager that has a car
that we could carpool and we could you
know get through the next few months I
could save up some cash and get a beater
um
I don't know I I think I probably just
need to do this I think I just need you
to tell me to do it
oh
because of where your head space is
I really like where you are and you've
because you have a proven track record
of winning already thirty six thousand
paid off out of 110. you're amazing
you're amazing and you what you have
decided let me say it a different way
out loud is you've decided I want to be
out of debt more than I want this car
yeah that's a fair trade
yeah I would make that trade because
you've also realized you can get another
car
when you have no debt
and you make 110 000 you can save up and
get a nice car pretty quick
right yeah absolutely
the one thing I would do different in
your plan than what you've said is I
would pay the car off
I would pay
whatever I could on those student loans
but I would say five thousand bucks to
go get me my own car
yeah yeah I wouldn't carpool the
teenager you all need to love each other
a little bit longer
yeah
adjusted too we talked about it this
morning and they were like well they
don't really get a vote they're a
teenager teenagers don't get a vote this
is just this is grown up to grown up but
I I I'd probably buy me a car
that I can get around with oh I'm okay
with that too you know three to five k
um and and you know because you do make
110 and you're gonna be done all we're
doing here is accelerating the
inevitable
you're gonna get out of debt yeah all
we're doing is doing it faster and then
the loop is the loopback is you're going
to go get another car 24 months from now
there's 20 grand and you're going to pay
cash for it
yeah then yeah you will because I mean
you'll have no debt and you'll have your
emergency phone in place and you would
upgrade out of a 5 000 car making 110.
what's your hang up yeah I would do it I
would do it
and I appreciate your teenagers
emotional
um uh support but it's not necessary
because you already are a warrior
princess you are already getting it done
and um and when it involves them
sacrificing they're never going to vote
for that so that's okay
okay
okay if this if
this one more one more little push
towards making this call
your kids are going to watch their mom
go all in yep and my mom look I remember
when I was a teenager what my mom did
when your daughter is or your son is a
grandparent they're going to be sitting
on the back porch yeah back when I was a
kid my mama sold off everything I
thought she's gonna sell me
my God she got out of debt and it
changed everything you'll be telling
that story or your kid's going to be one
year into grad school and thinking about
quitting and you're gonna say go all in
and he's gonna have a picture of what
that actually looks like
right yeah you're amazing it's pretty
awesome you're amazing well done very
very well done get them and should I
3000 came from a dealership yes
absolutely yes you should get more than
one quote we need to maximize this asset
okay yeah I get more than one quote and
consider taking an extra month to do it
and selling it private sale what kind of
car is it
it's a Toyota Tacoma it'll sell anyone
it'll sell fast you may want to sell it
private you look on Kelly Blue Book
um and that's a hot truck okay real hot
truck yeah that truck will sell it's a
good truck too
um and the uh but anyway I I would um
now look on Kelly Blue Book and see what
private sale is if it's 10 grand more
wait a month and sell it for eight grand
more to an individual
are you okay hey let me ask you go ahead
I'm gonna jump in because I hear there's
somebody's face that's in your mind
that's going to make fun of this
decision isn't there
I think that I just feel no no no no
you're not telling the truth you're not
there's isn't there answer my question
yeah yeah okay what I want you to do
right now I want you to stick your
tongue out at them
yeah because they don't get a vote in
your prosperity
in your peace in your sleep you're
amazing go with you I vote with you not
them
get them girl get them and Tacoma people
are a special I mean that's a gang
that's a capacity the tacos we had tacos
in our family now my friend Winston
drove one for 10 years Daniel drove one
for 10 years you're opting out of that
club to go to sleep well at night yeah
all right awesome today's question of
the day is brought to you by neighborly
your hub for Home Services as the
weather warms up neighborly can help you
find local service pros like the ground
Skies the five-star painting and
mosquito Joe to turn your outdoor space
into your favorite space find the help
you need these are great folks
neighborly.com today's question comes
from Shelly in Virginia Shelly writes my
son has a six-month emergency fund and
enough to save for a 25 down payment
he's been pre-approved for a mortgage
but it's asking me why an arm is a bad
choice not the body part but the
adjustable rate mortgage simple answer
I'm assuming this is a huge No-No I'd
love to know why simple answer it stands
for adjustable rate mortgage where have
interest rates been going lately
up what do we want to adjust up for
in a rising interest rate environment
that's dumber than a rock
you might have an argument in a falling
interest rate environment and then I'd
have to teach you a 20-minute class on
why arms suck
but but in addition to that just
straight up in a rising interest rate
environment you should never even have
to ask this question where you know
because I think rates are going to go
down then refinance but you do not want
the uh the arms came on the scene
because Banks got caught in an
escalating interest rate environment
with a bunch of low interest rate
mortgages in their portfolio that's
called disintermediation when Banks
don't like making not making money they
don't like this intermediation when
their portfolio is upside down compared
to the marketplace and so they invented
this thing where their portfolio adjusts
when rates go up
it's good for them and you pay for it
don't do an adjustable rate mortgage
ever ever under any circumstances you
have to do an arm you can't afford a
house this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
thanks for being with us Kelly is in
Oakland California hi Kelly welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hi Dave thank you so much for having me
sure what's up
um okay so my husband is a guarantor on
his mom's mortgage
um it's not under his name uh Jessica
guarantor we did a Cash out refinance of
her house prior to her creating a living
trust for um some Home Improvement
projects with the verbal expectation
that she would put the title in my
husband's name upon her passing however
without me knowing she threw in an
additional Clause that if we ever sell
the house we would be required to pay
half of the profits to his eldest son
who is currently 20 years old even
though we have two additional babies
under two years old
um this Clause was thrown in after the
loan was approved we've already thrown a
hundred thousand dollars of our own
money cash into the house the house is
worth as of right now conservatively
1.25 million and the current loan
balance is a little under 400 000.
so my question is now that we are out of
um baby step two and mom and dad
answered
um Mom
is unfortunately going through a lot of
Health situations and is she mentally
competent
yes she is okay your husband her son
needs to walk into her room with fresh
papers and have this fixed
she was in that was unethical
not fair and dumb and she needs to fix
it and she can do that with a signature
if your husband will make his mother do
that
okay
what happens if she doesn't because we
don't know yeah we don't know what to do
if I want her to sign it to a way to a
charity I don't want anything else to do
with it I want it sold and given away to
a charity I do not want to wreck a 20
year old irresponsible person's life
because you know what an irresponsible
person with 400 000 is really freaking
irresponsible
right dumb grandmother dumb dumb dumb
grandmother
right bad grandmother bad grandmother
bad bad bad bad bad bad do you have any
insight as to why she did this
um so she she wanted to make sure that
um her grandsons would be taking care of
when she's gone yeah it's an act of love
and she was dumb
really your husband allowed this I'm
angry with him too
because his mother has told him what to
do way too many times he's way too grown
up for this
mommy said and then Mommy did and he
didn't say anything about it because
Mommy Mother Dearest nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope and you're mad at her and
you need to be mad at him
it's easier to be mad at her because she
doesn't live in the house with you but
yeah but he's he's the one that allowed
this to go on and while he put his name
on the loan
I mean that's just unethical
on her part
and on his part very weak to allow this
to go down does she not trust your
husband
no she just had a fit of stupidity and
put it on paper I'm telling you it's not
I don't think it's deep stuff here
well I I think there is a little bit of
untrust before we got married he was
very bad with money and since then we've
turned everything around with all the
babies that got out of the bus giving it
to a 20 year old fixes that yeah what
are you gonna do
there's a lot of control issues mom has
um
that's spoken like somebody who really
loves her husband but man you're more
mom than you are a wife
he needs let's Saddle Up saddle up he
needs to March right in there and say
Mom this was wrong I went along with it
I shouldn't have and I'm not going along
with it so here's what's going to happen
you die I'm going to sue the trust and
ask the judge to undo your stupidity if
you don't undo it with his signature
right now because giving a 20 year old
four hundred thousand dollars is
absolutely that's irresponsible with
money is absolutely asinine because it's
going to cause more problems than
blessings
yeah okay it's not a blessing what is a
cocaine person what does a cocaine
addict do when they get more money more
cocaine
what's in irresponsible to a person do
when they get more money more
irresponsible what's a generous person
do when they get more money more
generous money magnifies our good and
bad parts that all of us have me
included
and uh you know what does Dave get more
things with loud mufflers you know I
mean what you know the redneck I mean
you know what but I mean everybody's got
right that so so let's let's back it out
let's say Grandma did this perfectly and
there's only one kid is the right thing
to do is to put it in an in a trust yeah
that has yeah multiple multi-year
payouts on it yeah yeah and different
different triggering mechanisms that
indicate responsibility like you know if
he's going to college I would graduate
college if you're going to go to college
you need to graduate college that's a
triggering event you need to uh be 25
and not be deeply in debt you know and a
triggering event you know and so some
level of maturity I'm not saying all 20
year olds are doofuses she said her 20
year old was irresponsible the mother
just said that okay so I'm that's what
I'm going off of so well he's been had a
ringside seat to his dad by the way I've
been a response when I was 20 you ain't
giving me 400 Grand that'd been a bad
idea it would have been the worst idea
I've been a lot of loud mufflers and
beer involved yeah yeah it's just a bad
idea no I'm not saying that everybody
but but and there there we've had 20
year olds on this show that were more
responsible and had their crap together
more than a lot of 60 year olds so you
can't can't it's not an age thing but
whatever you are good or bad is is going
to be magnified and when you're gifting
or doing inheritance you need to
structure it to ensure that you're being
a blessing and not magnifying stupidity
and let's go one step up the river here
a mother that would do this to her son
last minute dishonestly behind closed
doors without telling them has done this
crap for years she's a controller and if
you are married to somebody like this
you've got to speak up if you're married
to a coward who won't speak up against
his own mom or her own mom her own dad
or his own dad and say we as a family
are not getting into this deal and let
me tell you this is not a coward in the
sense of lack of Courage this is I don't
want to put up with the crap yes this is
going to unleash when I bother to have a
conflict with her because all conflicts
with her don't end well he just doesn't
want to screw with it I mean that's a
different kind of cowardice I don't
because I know it's you know when I walk
into the forest with the bear I'm gonna
meet a bear I mean he knows what he's
got he's dealt with it his whole life so
it's not cowardice like he's a little
wuss that's not the point he's like it
ain't worth a fight screw it that's
where he is but it is worth the fight we
spent a hundred thousand dollars it was
on money
and 400 going to an irresponsible 20
year old it's worth the fight it's worth
the fight it's worth calling her out and
oh by the way you signed the note so
that's what I mean doing business you
know some point you got to go it is
worth the fight but this is a this when
we say coward we're not like sniveling
yellow-bellied in the corner sucking
your thumb coward this is just I don't
want to deal with the pain in the butt
that is mom when you confront her but
the other side of that is it's your job
to protect your kid exactly and yourself
and your family yeah so that's your job
you know so this whole thing comes at
you you go you know what I'm not signing
that night I'm not going to do that
we're not gonna do that yeah
you want to do the deal we're doing it
my way yeah we'll do it my way or or not
at all it's okay and I also understand
hey there's a million dollar house we're
gonna have this much money
that's not worth losing my family over
not we're burning everything down I hold
dad gum
and Dave you spoke with for with such
Insight that
it's almost as though you've seen this
before 30 years of doing this yes yeah
yeah a couple times parents and
grandparents who try to bless their
their lineage and they bless you know
the worst one I ever had early on on
this show I took a call from a
grandfather who was sobbing and he was
he was uh 89 years old
and he had co-signed for a 30 000 pickup
for his grandson
and it got repoed
and they were coming after his farm
because he had no money but he had a
farm oh no and they were going to take
the 89 year old's farm for the
repossession on the pickup
and nobody in the family
he thought he was helping his grandson
by co-signing and I'll never forget that
89 year old crying on the air this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's John deloney co-host of the
Ramsey show did you know over 18 million
NP show every week a lot of those people
listed on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country to find a
station near you go to
ramseysolutions.com show
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsey show where we help people
filled well do work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships open
phones around here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five my co-host
today Dr John deloney of Dr John deloney
show a podcast on Ramsey networks that
is unbelievably fabulously popular and
of course number one best-selling book
of own your past change your future he
deals with the mental health space and
the relationship space and uh so always
a fun one-two punch when he and I get to
serve together on these microphones open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Naomi is in Green Bay
Wisconsin hey Naomi what's up
hi um first I just want to say thank you
so much
so much that I've been listening to you
a lot over the past couple months I
guess I'm a new new listener and um it's
just so obvious and apparent that
everybody there genuinely cares about
the people you're dealing with and
really tries to help and I just find
that so inspiring and encouraging in
today's society so thank you that's the
best compliment I've had today thank you
very much I appreciate that that's true
and thank you for noticing that how can
we help you
um so I'm calling because I have a
question about how to deal with or
manage ongoing medical expenses it's not
one lump sum it's not one thing
um my son is sick he's been sick for 10
years and
um over the course of the 10 years you
know there's been some ups and downs but
you could say that the medical expenses
have you know probably averaged about 20
percent of our income and
um yeah and my husband is uh he's a
pastor so there hasn't always been a
whole lot of income you know to go
around to pay things so
um we don't have a lot of debt in fact
we we only own our house I don't know
how we could afford to do what we do if
we had anything like a car payment or
anything how old is your baby
well now he's 16. he he was six what's
the nature of his illness
chronic lyme disease
um 15 of people who get Lyme disease it
doesn't go away with the 30-day
treatment of antibiotics and he actually
got it when he was three and a half
which made it more severe he didn't get
the normal kind of treatment that adults
would get like a strong enough
antibiotic so he's got some neurological
things going on
yeah and he he's been up and down like
he actually was doing a lot better and
then he got covered he I mean he got
covered two years ago and that put
everything way back set him back to
debilitating headaches in the treatment
protocol that we found that had been
working for four or five years suddenly
wasn't and it's like a whole new amount
of medical expenses and things trying to
get him back to where he can you know at
least function even houses energy level
today
energy
um he
he he's better he actually with the
covid he started getting like
debilitating migraines yeah that was
three years that was three years ago
how is he today Lord was like
how old is he today how is he today
he's he
not as good as he was
2020 but he's better than
a 2022 so I guess he's in the middle
okay so here's what the reason I'm
asking you all these things is number
one to check on him but number two what
you've you're calling about is how to
budget for this and of course it's
impossible to predict exactly but we can
say
based on what we know of the history
the covet episode and the improvements
since covid based on that not emotions
but what does logic tell you
factually that you think is a reasonable
forecast for the coming three or four
years
that you're going to be paying medical
expenses
and I assume you've got a health
insurance as well so you know what out
of pocket do you need to budget
for a reasonable person that would
project what you guys have been facing
because it is a chronic thing you're
dealing with it's ongoing
and the only question is how bad it is
going forward not how bad it has been
but how bad it is going forward now I
know you and I can't project we're not
God but you can tell me based on his
prognosis today take your mommy uh heart
which is wonderful and set it aside for
a second just look at it from your brain
and say based on where he is today where
do you really think you're going to
spend in the next
12 months and 24 months and 36 months
and then just put that in the budget
monthly
if you think it's going to be ten
thousand dollars put eight hundred
dollars a month in the budget out of
pocket I'm talking about
if you think it's going to be three
thousand dollars put 250 a month in the
budget
and so uh you know anytime you're
dealing with something chronic you just
I've got a friend that has Crohn's
disease and he's you know he's got a
just a it's a constant thing it's a
chronic issue and he's constantly
writing checks he's constantly making
his deductible he's constantly making
his co-pays right because it's just he
just fights with health it's just it's
sad it's awful it's hard on him he's
tough as nails but man and but that's
the thing you gotta you just gotta you
gotta go okay quantify it because you're
asking me about the budget so we got to
quantify it so six thousand dollars a
year 500 bucks a month I'm just gonna
put it in the month like I got a car
payment
and I'm just gonna put it on there set
it aside I don't need it this month
don't need it next month but I'm gonna
need it sometime during this 12. it's
probably going to happen and so I got to
get ready and we're just you know and uh
it's uh here's what's weird when you do
that math and you lay it all out it will
calm you down about his health
hello okay yes yes I'm here
um so
so if the amount I put in the budget
which I would say would I don't know
maybe like sixteen hundred dollars a
month but then that just makes our
budget tend to not work
are you really gonna spend 1600 a month
yeah that's twenty thousand dollars a
year absolutely twenty thousand dollars
a year out of pocket out of pocket
well it was more than that last year I
didn't ask about last year I asked about
next year
18 or 16 000 out of pocket next year
Okay then if that's if that's what
you're really going to spend then you
really need to put that in your budget
and here's a hard conversation that
you're all gonna have to have
um I had somebody call into my show this
morning and we have a very similar
conversation him and his wife adopted
they had a beautiful two-year-old
daughter and then his wife passed away
and he was set up to be a high powered
accountant and he had to change his
career trajectory
and take a totally different kind of
role because that his life changed
and maybe your husband has wanted to be
a pastor he's in it but reality
financially is sitting before him saying
you can't continue to make this much
money in this kind of job and take care
of your sick child and that's a hard
conversation it's a conversation that no
one none of us want to have especially
when we feel like we've got a calling
but man we've got to look at our kids
and the way I would phrase this is we
have to choose reality we got to own
reality that sits before us there's a
financial reality and a purpose reality
all those things are real if you can't
afford it you got to find something
figure out something else and without
you guys facing what that Mom's facing
is very real very real very scary we got
a guy named Chris at work here yeah and
he's out on he's on disability
so
ouch this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys if you're wondering whether to
buy or sell a home this year here's what
you need to know about the housing
market there's still more demand for
homes
than there are homes to buy there's
still a shortage median home price is
expected to keep Rising
just at a slower rate than the crazy
time back in covet but I mean it's still
going up and interest rates hadn't
stopped going up so what's this mean it
means if you're buying a home you may
still face competition to big price tags
and if you wait you're going to face
more competition more price tags so if
you want to sell your home good time to
sell it but of course it's going to sell
slower than the crazy times when you got
89 offers in one weekend those days are
gone and they should be gone they were
not healthy so it's good life is good to
buy a home to sell a home Now's the Time
go to ramseysolutions.com to find an
agent that we recommend
ramseysolutions.com agent they're Ramsay
trusted these are top performing agents
around the country who our team has
vetted and trusts to serve you well they
did not get their license last week and
they've not sold only two homes and
they're not your uncle well probably
because you know you don't pick your
agent by
him being your uncle
or a friend at church who just got her
license and she's so sweet no that's
just dumb don't do that you're about to
lose money on your house don't do that
Jessica is with us in Philadelphia hi
Jessica how are you
hi Dave I'm doing great and freaking out
a little bit because I made it on air
with you how about you ah I'm freaking
out because I made it on air with you
what's up
Jessica he is freaked out trust me trust
me this is Dave freaked out
so uh my question is
we sold our home last year when you know
prices were ridiculous and we have a
good amount of money to put into
um a 529 and Esa for our children
but I don't want to trigger a gift tax
I'm pretty sure that has nothing to do
with the gift tax
okay because um you can double check
your tax guy because I'm not a thousand
percent sure but I've never heard of
somebody who hit it getting hit with a
gift tax putting money into a 529
to start with you'd have to put in more
than whatever the limit is a sheer
twelve thousand fifteen thousand bucks
whatever it is but um I can't even
remember cheat sheet here but anyway
yeah
so uh
uh well that's what I was running in 16
000. no 16 000. if you're going over
sixteen thousand you'd have a gift tax
this year but the uh uh but
um yeah I but I'm pretty sure this has
nothing to do with gift tax I'm pretty
sure if you're putting it into the
college fund that doesn't apply to this
pretty sure if you put it in your minor
children's name it doesn't apply to this
but um but I'm not positive so you could
double check your Tax Advisor if you're
working with a smart investor Pro to
open the 529 or if you have a 529 with
them they certainly could answer the
question uh they would know off the top
of their head but I've never heard of
somebody being gift tax doing that so I
doubt I'm pretty sure it's exempt from
that
so but again double check because my tax
I'm always quick to say when I'm not
positive and I'm not
positive on that one Tim's in Cedar
Rapids Iowa hi Tim welcome to the Ramsey
Show
for you thanks for taking my call sure
what's up
um so I'm 39 I'm completely debt free
good
um yeah well I guess I shouldn't say
that we own a we own a downtown building
that we owe 38 000 on
um we are gonna be hey I'm John Maloney
and I'm six feet tall except I'm five
eight no I I know I forgot to say that
um I have 160 000 saved up cash
um and we're looking at probably going
to be building a house next year cool
um we own where we at far right now so
we're probably going to tear down the
existing home and build
um on our place
um I want to take and pay off the
building right now
um is that is that something you would
the wife doesn't really want me to what
but if she doesn't think it's gonna she
doesn't
how'd she put it she doesn't think she
doesn't see the problem of making the
monthly payment on it or the 200 or
whatever that we owe on yeah okay we can
just turn that over to the house yeah if
it's not a problem then it won't be a
problem when it's paid off either
correct it's your her point was it's
irrelevant so it's irrelevant pay it off
um it's not irrelevant because you're
going to be have a different switch that
flips inside of you when you have
absolutely zero debt now what's your
household income
oh I'd say probably right at 100. okay
so what are you gonna how much you're
gonna spend on the building project
well right now we're looking at maybe
160 000 180 000 house that's why she
doesn't want you to pay off the building
because you're going to turn around with
120 000 how you're gonna have the money
to build the house you want
interactive because I mean we still got
to keep twenty thousand in our emergency
fund yeah well you got 160 you said but
if we pay off a forty thousand dollar
thirty eight thousand dollar mortgage we
can leave me 120 and you're wanting to
build 160 so where you're gonna get the
other 40. that's why she doesn't want to
do it
correct yeah that's it so instead of
having a mortgage on our house she would
rather you have a mortgage on the
building and I'm probably agreeing with
that
what's the house oh you're you're
tearing down a prop you own the land
already and you're living on the land
now
correct okay where are y'all gonna live
when you tear the house down
um we're either gonna have to rent a
place or possibly a radio have a camper
we can live in
um yeah all right so budget the
house carefully because 160
000 even in Cedar Rapids
is certainly not the uh it's not a
mansion
no no it's it's just an easy well let me
tell you you can blink and this will be
260. right yeah I know so you need to
lay out a game plan
in detail and start drawing a plan
and figuring out your you know your
actual materials cost your actual
contractor cost what are you really
going to do
um I'm building a home right now and uh
me and the Builder have uh had a lot of
discussions for three months before we
broke ground and we have three pieces of
paper we met last night and we managed
to these three pieces of paper the
schedule the budget and the blueprint
and we have to stay on track on all
three the schedule the blueprint bow is
all planned on paper before three months
before we broke ground
we ordered ordered the windows and the
appliances of two months before we broke
ground because of supply chain
they'll be sitting in the warehouse
early
so we're not going to slow down we're
going to be on time we're going to be on
budget and we're going to stick to the
freaking plan
and if you don't do that you're a
nightmare for your Builder and you're
going to blow your budget up and you're
going to be four years building a
pretzel
you follow me
so if you if you guys will do all that
planning and laying out then you may
figure out we're not going to bill for a
little while we're going to save money
for a little bit more
that could be a possibility too yeah it
could be I don't care what you do you
may you may choose to bill for 120 and
pay off the building
I don't care you can do you can do any
of these you want to do but here's what
you're right now you have a vague
statement of what we want to build a
house and that's the end of your
information you don't have any more
information other than you want to put
it on that lot where that house is you
got now that you're going to tear down
but you really need I I want you looking
at blueprints I want you talking to the
Builder I want you to get budgets and
Supply you know what's your Lumber
package you're gonna run you know how
long is this going to take because if
it's going to take two years if it's
going to be three years from now before
you need to write the last check well
you can afford to save up a lot making a
hundred
I also want you guys to sit down and
create a five to ten year plan for your
family because you really want to get
this building paid off she doesn't want
to have a mortgage on this new house
y'all planning on building and she wants
a new house and she wants a new house in
some ways are kicking some of this down
the road sit down and let's come up and
you have a game plan for your house have
a game plan for your marriage have a
game plan for your finances over the
next five to ten years yeah and just and
just follow the plan out we're at the
end of the story we're living in the
house she wants paid for and the
building's paid for there you go and now
what number of months out there is that
five 60 months is it 64 months and you
can lay that out it's it's sixth grade
math Dave I had a buddy in college that
was connected to the building industry
and one of the a builder told him
something important once he said I can
always tell the difference between the
millionaires who are buying a house and
the middle class guys with the big loan
because the millionaires come in with
the ads from The Appliance Store it said
we agreed on this one and the middle
class guy with the big loan says I don't
know man what do you think and he said
there was that attention to detail gonna
do it like this that preserves that um
that millionaire status over time I told
my Builder I'm gonna pay him a little
extra because I'm about to drive him and
my wife crazy
I'm a project manager from hell I mean
it's just detail man it's detail this is
the Ramsay show
[Music]
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees ever
guarantee and shipping is always free
see why blinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings go to blinds.com now and save
40 off selected products visit
blinds.com today for more info
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for being with us
America open phone's a triple eight
eight two five five two two five thanks
for being here hey based on our rankings
we're in the top 10 podcasts in the
entire world top 15 podcasts in the
entire world
uh and that has gone up recently uh
based on our ratings on radio uh based
on our Spotify and our Apple numbers and
our YouTube numbers there's a whole
bunch of you that are new thank you
we're honored to have you in our
audience uh we will love you and we will
tell you the truth and sometimes that
will make you mad just be prepared
because we love you and we will tell you
the truth that's what we do and if you
want to help us we're not going to spend
300 million on marketing like a sofa
we're not buying a uh like a football
stadium or something
allergies are bad this time of year and
um but the uh if you want to help us you
can subscribe
follow the show whatever it is whichever
way you do it click the Subscribe button
click the follow button click the share
button and send it on
send it on yeah send it on to them and
uh good stuff
let people know about leave us a five
star review
mama said if you hang anything nice to
say don't say anything at all so five
stars work thank you very much we're
glad you're here we appreciate you being
with us Williams in San Antonio Texas
Remember the Alamo what's up William
oh good afternoon uh Dave
I uh had a rather unfortunate Financial
incident in in our marriage
happened last fall my wife uh got
victimized in an internet fraud
and not only lost a sizable amount of
cash but also
took out some loans to help these
people
and uh some of those were short-term
credit card things like buying gift
cards
and then there were two installment
loans
one was for twenty three thousand five
hundred
one was for 17 500.
the rest of them the smaller credit
cards and such
I'm using the snowball method to take
care of those but I need advice on the
installment loans
when it comes to this uh
fraud it's usually one of two things
usually it's some sort of
romantic interest or it's some sort of
somebody crying out for help with
medical assistance or some sort of
Injustice
what is it in your in your in your
situation
oh
it would it would be the former uh
my wife and I have been having been
having some uh problems been together
for 25 years
and uh
things just kind of uh I don't know they
happened and I didn't didn't see the
warning signs
how's your marriage now but
it's it's much better I've been I've
been getting therapy and she has been
too and we've been making some inroads
and just uh basic stuff like how we
speak to each other and I'm proud of you
man it's hard try try it well here's the
thing I I have a bunch of people tell me
well I would I would divorce somebody
that would do that and I I'm not going
to throw away 25 years
okay I I said I would make a full year
as a concerted effort to get this thing
turned around financially and
emotionally and part of the emotional
thing is me I realized I needed to do
some
some work uh and so we're both doing
therapy and it seems to be benefiting
well you're you're a beacon of light for
men who are find themselves in in
emotional situations without the right
tools in the toolkit and you can do one
of two things you can just take up your
toolkit and go home or you can you can
storm the gates of hell and try to find
more tools and that's what you're doing
man I'm proud of you I'm proud of you
amen thank you it's awesome what's your
household income sir
so 69
okay
um does she work outside the home
no we're we're both in our mid 70s no
we're both retired
oh boy
so there there's money there to take
care of the short-term stuff
the the I mean you mean money you have a
nest egg
uh we we still have some resources a
401k and I have some I have some money
in my account all the debts are in her
name what is the uh how much money is in
your account
forty five thousand dollars how much
money is in your 401k
Blues slightly I'm not counting these
two installment loans how much
miscellaneous is there
the little credit card mosquitoes
yeah I'm gonna say nine ten thousand
all right
um
I've got an income tax refund check
coming in the 2000's gonna get knocked
off for that
and I would write a check out I would
write a check out of yours today and pay
off all the credit cards that leaves the
40 and close all the accounts okay now
that is a gesture on your part towards
the healing that you're searching for
the 40 is still sitting there we'll come
back to that in a minute then I want to
meet with her and her therapist and your
therapist and however y'all are doing
this marriage stuff and uh somehow
you've got to get some checks and
balances and start to incrementally
rebuild trust that you're not throwing
good money after bad this doesn't happen
again because in the back of your mind
you're if I clean this out and this
happens again I ain't got anywhere to go
that's what's happening in the back of
your mind so you've got to know that
this is solid going forward before you
write any more big checks
but nine thousand but nine thousand
dollars in the scope of your life you
would pay that right now for healing
and I would yeah yeah let's let's get
rid of all the mosquitoes get it down to
the 17 5 and 20. three five and then
let's just sit there with those two
while we work on this relationship and
as your trust reaches closer to 100
percent and that is going to require
some demonstrations as well as on her
part and your part and healing and some
time to rebuild and as that is rebuilt
and you approach 100 on that then I'm
gonna start trying to figure out a way
to get those paid off but right now I
want to clear the the white noise the
Clutter out of my mind with all these
little bills that because every time you
write a check on this it picks the scab
it opens the wound
and I'm trying to get it down to right
in just two checks
it's very perceptive you're right
yeah I mean I get pissed off all all
over again every time you do this and
you have to go through the whole process
you've been doing in therapy start
forgiveness again you start have to go
back through the whole thing and you
just you start having all these
conversations between your ears we all
do this that's how I know I I wouldn't
be guilty of it no not me but yeah but I
mean yeah you write checks for things
you're that remind you of bad things
it's bad so Dave at what point
does and again in service of choosing
reality disowning this is where we find
ourselves do two people in their 70s
have to commit to going back to work for
a year and earn another forty thousand
dollars to pay these debts if she's of
good health
I mean I would talk to her therapist
about this I'm not going to intervene in
that but if she's of good health
um so it's like both of them she's
trying to re-earn trust
and
um you know I'm 12 stepping here but uh
you know make them make good make amends
yeah I think she goes back to work yeah
and starts working on these other two
loans I I think that's not because of
financial but just I think that's a
representative movement towards owning
this it will give a place for that
energy too you know you know make amends
it is a 12-step thing and so you got to
go back and where you can correct the
wrongs it's part of being repentant or
sorry
you know and nobody wants to work in
their 70s and that's where we find
ourselves right and nobody wants to get
scammed to buy a romance on the internet
that's where we find ourselves this is
the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Brian
is with us in Austin Texas hey Brian
welcome to the Ramsay show
hey Dave honored to talk to you Sarah
and grateful for your ministry and my
wife and I are recently we've discovered
you guys and the baby steps and
um we're beginning to think we're doing
everything a little backwards and now
we've learned about your stuff so
specifically we have three debt items so
we have two car notes and then a
mortgage those three items uh no credit
card debt cars are 55 and 20 uh so about
75 total however we built up some
savings and Investments
um just in index funds uh it's like 180
around there and then we have more on
that and retirement so my question is we
want to send our kids just because just
concerns about you know School
curriculum all that stuff we want to
send them to Christian private school
and what our question is is how do we
pay for that like should we I was
thinking of just tapping in and drawing
from our investments and paying that
roughly 10 grand a year but then my wife
had a good idea we're listening to you
and so we're like man or do we just pay
the car notes off first what's your
household income
uh 94 actually well my wife's gonna be
working part-time so uh in the fall so
um it'll be about 100 105 somewhere
where did the 180 come from
uh I used to before my job now I used to
be in a higher income earning job
why aren't you now
uh because I'm in vocational full-time
Ministry now oh okay okay yeah that's
fine I'm just curious okay so yeah
because the numbers just didn't they
didn't that didn't add up okay and um
that's good
um
what's the score cost
it's 10 grand a year per kid
um well it'll be for both of them okay
okay so 10 grand out of 105 is a budget
item
and you write a check pay off the cars
but I'm not sure a fifty five thousand
dollar car fits in the 105 000 income
matter of fact I'm sure it doesn't
re even if it's paid for even if it's
paid for what in the world is that
oh the car Mama's SUV
no no this is Dad's truck he's in Austin
uh no well almost there's a Tesla that's
really good I gave up my my uh older car
and finally you're a hipster Pastor man
yeah so that's cool
um yeah here's the thing we so what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes
and why why is important because I want
you to think for yourself not do stuff
and you wouldn't do stuff just because
Dave said Brian but
um so what we've discovered
mathematically is it's very difficult to
get ahead when a large portion of your
asset base versus your income is
depreciating going down in value like a
rock
and um so all cars with wheels and or
Motors go anything with wheels and or
Motors goes down in value period
now so when you have too many things
with wheels and Motors that go down in
value versus your income and this did
fit in your old life
yeah because you were probably making
200 or more and so uh you know 55 000
our car is not a problem but where what
the numbers that we've crunched over 30
years of doing this say that if you've
got more than half of your annual income
tied up in things going the wrong way
you're going to struggle so I would
challenge whether to keep the Tesla or
not you need to pray about that think
about it I'm not going to tell you what
to do but you've got too much tied up in
things going the wrong way versus your
income that's what I'm observing now so
at a minimum I'd rather check and pay
them off today
The Next Step I would consider is
stepping out that Tesla and moving into
a more reasonable vehicle for somebody
that makes a hundred thousand a year
okay yeah that's fair that makes sense
and I think you can handle a ten
thousand dollar budget out of 105 if you
watch your p's and q's and just send
your kids to school as a budget item
yeah
yeah okay and I'm guessing they're going
to school where you're pastoring
yeah well it's it's similar philosophy
different place but yeah it's real
similar yeah okay something where you
know the uh
the curriculum and the output and so
forth you're not you're not having to
wonder what kind of garbage they're
getting fed right yeah exactly things
are getting a little crazy so it made us
rethink everything yeah I heard the
rumor yeah
a little yeah a lot okay so yeah I'm
with you I'm with you on that part and I
and the ratio for private school is a
good ratio you got a great deal
10 grand for two of them that's that's
amazingly cheap you know in today's
world so all of that the the biggest
thing that doesn't fit in this math
picture is that Tesla just to pick on it
again and so you can do what you want uh
if I woke up in your shoes I would be
driving a twenty thousand dollar car not
a fifty five thousand dollar car and
um and my wife would be driving her
twenty thousand dollar car and we'd have
a little more money in the bank and we'd
be budget idming these kids so you're
right on track and thank you for your
service and thank you for your hard
choice to serve to serve in the ministry
that's that's a real call to take an
income cut in half or more and to do
that that's pretty cool yeah that's real
cool open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five Ryan is in
Phoenix hey Ryan what's up
hi Dave I'm a big fan and I just
finished reading Dr Malone's book
um I got a question about my home so uh
we have a condo uh we currently owe 208
000 but we're still paying a PMI of 180
a month good god
um we also to get under the PMI they say
it'll be twenty four thousand seven
hundred and eleven dollars
um I have cash on hand of actually 33
000. so I could pay that off but I also
have 92 000 in student loans so I didn't
know if I should take that cash on hand
and apply it directly to student loans
or pay off the PMI what's your household
uh well so I just recently lost my job
but it I'm I'm applying right now once I
get my job back our household income
should be anywhere from 140 to 150. okay
and how long have you been working on uh
this debt situation
only a month
um I graduated in May and a week later I
lost my job so during that time I went
through Financial Peace University with
my wife we got on board with the budget
but we're like okay it's really hard to
set a budget because because I'm
unemployed yeah okay yeah so all right
so remember in Financial Peace
University when we talked about we get
rid of all debt
except the house and baby step two
and the PMI didn't change that PMI
pisses me off I'm with you it's bad yeah
but and I want you to get that other 24
on there as fast as you can but I want
your student loans gone because they're
getting ready to come back at you guys
with these student loans they're going
to return that Fellowship back on
yeah I haven't had a payment so it felt
like nothing but yeah okay now you do
but I mean it's getting it's gonna it's
gonna wake you back up man in the fall
and then when it comes becomes very
apparent that the Biden Administration
is not able to forgive student loans
so um yeah I mean the Supreme Court has
ruled and it's you know I'm sorry but so
uh sorry but not sorry so the 33 000 you
remember baby step one's a thousand
dollars everything else goes towards the
debt and so 32 goes on the 92 so now we
have 60 left and we're going to attack
the 60 with a Vengeance and when it's
gone we're gonna build an emergency fund
and when it's gone we're going to start
putting 15 of our income into retirement
and kids college and start paying down
on the house and that's when you'll get
rid of the PMI
perfect thank you so much okay thank you
thank you for being a customer in
Financial Peace Welcome to our crazy
gang Dave I think what you said is real
important man if you have not been
paying in on student loans
and no one has by the way statistics for
three years one percent have been paying
if you haven't
they are coming back in September
like a forest fire they're coming make a
plan that might mean you've got to
cancel a vacation that might mean you
gotta sell something that might mean
whatever listen you think inflation
sucks white or your student loans kicked
back in and you didn't think about it
and they catch you off guard you've got
a four-month Runway to solve this slam
your face in the bricks guys so get make
a plan don't don't don't don't act like
this isn't coming it's coming
[Music]
red here and get rid of your student
loans people this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships open phones
here Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Clayton is with us in San Diego to start
off this hour hi Clayton welcome to the
Ramsey Show
sure what's up
question today is is it a smart decision
to accept my parents help to pay off my
debt
um to give a little backstory I'm 27
years old making 85 000 a year I
currently have thirty thousand dollars
of debt 25 of that is in credit cards
and five of that is a card note
um I just recently had to put in ten
thousand dollars of repairs in my car
um and my parents are offering to help
pay for half of that
um and I just recently kind of stumbled
onto your guys's show and uh binge
watched it on YouTube and I have uh
heard that that might not be the best
idea going forward
uh so just wondering how to figure out
how to uh whether your mom and dad are
offering you five thousand dollars in
assistance as you start walking out of
debt yes what strings are attached
they're a great support
for you know any bills or anything like
that for probably 10 years now
um and you're 27 so since you were 17
. since I was about 8 19 yeah
um I moved out around then and started
working so why now
uh I think my my parents just know how
stressed I was for uh you know I was
working on getting out of debt and then
um I was I was tripping away at it and
then having a ten thousand dollar issue
um this car has been I've had it for
about five years and I've put about
twenty thousand dollars into it so they
know that it's been an absolute headache
for me so I think that they're uh you
must be the worst at purchasing car
repairs in the world you spent thirty
thousand dollars literally you're not
exaggerating repairing a car
twenty twenty thousand twenty thousand
oh including this ten
uh this this is yes what in the world
did you rebuild the whole car
I mean I've had I've had an air
conditioning I've had like a multiple
sensor issues and then this recent one
was a hybrid battery replacement that
was about ninety seven hundred dollars
yeah oh you're driving a battery yes yes
no it's a it's an Audi it's an Audi but
it's an electric vehicle yeah but it's
an electric vehicle yes sir oh that
e-tron I know
you're telling me no you told us and
we're we're not laughing at you it's
with you but it's kind of at you yeah
yeah
couch
so something is stirring in your soul my
guess is you you went in a rabbit hole
watched all these videos of the Ramsay
show you're looking at your financial
position you make 85 Grand as a 27 year
old which is which is means you're
crushing it and you can't breathe and
the more you listen to this show the
more your heart's beating a little bit
faster and a little bit faster a little
bit faster is that fair
that is absolutely fair and then your uh
control all delete doesn't work on your
rolling girder or whatever you got in
your car there and now you're in a mess
so the the car is the car been fixed now
already been fixed
has been fixed um so I I did use this is
before I I realized this was an absolute
No-No but I did use debt to
um pay for the repairs on the car um so
I put it on a credit card which that
adds into the 25 000.
um yeah what is this what's the Toyota
battery worth the car I mean what's it
worth uh no I thought it was it was an
Audi Audi Audi I'm sorry yeah it's about
uh 13 and a half so
um we're getting about 13 000. I have it
on you know the different sites okay for
about 14. so what is bothering you about
your parents offering you no strings
attached they have a good relationship
with you you've been living on your own
not with any help at all there's no
pattern of subsidy
what's bothering you about five thousand
dollars worth of help
chances that do make it a smart decision
um or you know or okay to do yeah where
there's where there's not a pattern of
you being a parasite
it's okay
yeah okay this is just a gift it's like
a wildly generous Christmas gift
but or where there's a pattern of mom
and dad now get to help you make all
your decisions because they are going to
invade your life because they're control
freaks because they put some money and
we wouldn't we wouldn't do that one I
didn't hear either one of those things
here or it becomes an entitlement you
expect this forever you've been you've
been managing on your own you've made
some mistakes but welcome to life you're
not doing horribly you're just not doing
great and you have this battery blow up
and they want to give you 5K I take it
they have the money
uh they do they're not you know they're
not rolling but they're but they do all
right for themselves borrow the money to
give you 5K no no they wouldn't all
right
um well I wouldn't want to tell I would
tell you to not engage in a pattern for
your sake for your dignity this is not a
pattern it's a one-off it's an anomaly
so if eight months from now they won't
do it again no no I think we you know
we're just this helps you turn the
corner
on this new adventure you're on to
become debt free
but they've not been supporting you
you've been supporting yourself for
seven eight nine years and uh and
they're not control freaks I haven't
heard a single thing now is are you
going to tell me something in just a
minute that I haven't heard yet no no
there's nothing hidden or anything like
that okay I think it was just maybe like
a A prizing or not hey that's a good
kind of Pride to ask the question
so uh but you know uh uh my kids do
fabulously they make really good money
they stand on their own they've done
great on their wealth building and you
know as part of my estate planning I may
just dump some money over there but it
has nothing to do with them uh you know
it has nothing I'm not doing that but I
mean it could but I'm just saying it has
nothing to do with me controlling them
it has nothing to do with them being
needy in a parasite living in their
mother's basement playing video games
that's not what we're doing you're a
stand-up citizen making 85k in San Diego
California you're not rich but you have
a plan and now you've got a new nuanced
plan that gives you some traction I'm
proud of you let this be the fire that
engages this system so that the next
time and it would there will be a next
time
yeah when a car falls apart on you that
that you don't have to call mom and dad
that you've paid off this debt you're
staying on your own two feet I don't
even think you called them they called
you
yeah it was yeah I was just kind of you
know you were you were whining about it
and they said hey we'll help exactly
yeah yeah that's that's fair so he you
know maybe passive aggressive calling
yeah I mean he didn't he didn't call and
beg for money yeah so that's that's cool
Clayton I like you I think you're a good
guy I think you're heading the right way
man yeah except the gift and and make
this be a let this be a never again
moment yeah I'm gonna give you another
gift so accept this one we want to put
you through Financial Peace University
and accelerate this process so Mom and
Dad will throw a little gas on your fire
we'll throw some on your fire we want
you to go through the program the whole
nine weeks if you'll promise to go
through it we'll give it to you free
hang on Austin will pick up
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Dr John deloney here I'm a huge fan
of both meditation and prayer and good
mental health includes slowing down
gaining control of your thoughts and
plugging into something bigger than you
and Halo makes it easy to start a daily
practice of meditation prayer and
finding peace hallow is the number one
Bible app in the world and you can
tailor content towards your faith
tradition from scripture readings and
prayers to meditation and journaling
hallow makes it easy to practice prayer
meditate and build a deeper more
meaningful spiritual life and ReDiscover
true peace go to hollow.com Ramsay today
to get three months of hallow for free
that's hallow.com Ramsay
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today our team's been doing
research on Mental Health in the
workplace
it's not looking good out there guys
employees say the last month they felt
stressed burned out overwhelmed even
angry at work and if you're a business
or HR leader you may be seeing this
firsthand your employees can be
distracted exhausted maybe even quit or
ready to quit here's the deal good
leaders take their employees well-being
seriously and because it's good for both
you or employees and your business when
they're well they can bring their full
selves to work and you can help them do
that this is employee well-being month
and that includes Financial Wellness our
major companies across U.S like U-Haul
and Costco and many others are teaching
our curriculum to their employees it's
called smart dollar when it's done by
the HR team and lots of companies
furnish our our stuff to show people how
to become wealthy get out of debt get
the money piece straightened out that
lower stress big time go to
ramseysolutions.com employee well-built
being to check out some free resources
ramsaysolutions
employee well-being Jared is in Salt
Lake City hey Jared welcome to the
Ramsay show how can we help
yeah hi hi John hi Dave how are you
doing today great man what's up
good hey so I have a bit of an odd
question so about a year ago I was
diagnosed with uh brain cancer
um you don't don't feel too bad for me I
you know I've still got my hair I'm up
and walking but the diagnosis comes with
about a 10 to 15 year time Horizon for
uh for death I'm 32 I have two kids and
a wife
um we're in steps four five and six as
far as the baby steps are concerned and
really my question is just
so I intend to beat this diagnosis
however
I do want to live with the brutal facts
and and just want to know if there's
anything I should change or adjust about
the plan that we have laid out
to take into account that I made uh you
know evaporate from from being the
financial provider for my family in a
decade
man how long ago was the diagnosis
about a year about a year ago
man you process this uh and
you know the tone of your voice and the
way you present the story just is
incredible courage
you sound so strong I mean it's I'm I'm
about to cry but you sound so strong
Jared have you gone robot mode
no no so when I first got this diagnosis
it was a lemon-sized tumor in my brain
and they told me I had six months to
live
um I was lucky that my tumor is about as
weird as I am uh and because of that uh
they found out no you don't have six
months the the structure of the genes
and this tumor mean that you've got
about 10 to 15 years not six months and
so I sat in in that first diagnosis for
about a month before they got the
testing back and that gives you a lot of
time to kind of process yeah and then
you know yeah so you got like a 10-year
gift is the way you've been looking at
it yeah exactly wow exactly good for you
man hold your kids
I've got a three-year-old and a one
one-year-old he was actually born uh the
same month as my uh my surgery my
craniotomy
wow okay
and so let me go back now that I'm
breathing again what was your question
exactly how can you best prepare you're
in baby steps four five and six and how
can you best prepare
okay yeah so we're we're anticipating
I'm gonna live for a really long time
but I have also been given the blessing
of knowing that that might not be the
case and how do I change my plan to uh
to adopt that knowledge yeah in a nine
and a half year bonus plan I don't yeah
roughly yeah so possibly probably okay
um
ah
the way I answer questions here is what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes I
can't imagine
because I've never been there
the first thing uh
I have done years ago and I would do
over and over every morning and I have
done ever over and every morning is just
make sure I'm spiritually in order
that yeah I've got my spiritual house in
order and and that's inside of me and
it's between me and God and
um in my case I'm a Jesus follower and
so that becomes a huge huge deal in
these scenarios now once I've got that
going then for me then the second thing
I'm going to be worried about is
relationships and make sure I'm not like
John said in robot mode or in freak out
mode or in I'm not doing more damage
um then uh
you know uh then good you know with this
diagnosis and so
um you know it's the
um uh yeah and the third thing I'm going
to do is go write a bull named Foo menu
I mean I'm gonna do a bunch of stuff
right and so uh uh which I do I've
always done that I jumped out of an
airplane made John deloney do it with me
last year so
um you know you might as well you know
and why not and uh and then the fourth
thing I'm gonna do is a question you're
asking so is the financial and I've
already done all of that now also so I
can speak that what I would do is what
I've done a detailed will and I'm gonna
write letters to go with that will
for weddings
and for births of grandchildren that I
might not be there for and I'm going to
have a lot of discussions with everybody
that's around uh as to exactly how I
want this financial thing to go down and
it's all going to be written out in a
detailed will exactly how I want the
money handled for the good of my family
right and by the way that's what I have
I have a ridiculously complicated and
detailed estate plan but that's one way
I say I love you to my family and that's
what you're asking so I want you to make
sure that that's done and if you spend a
little money on that it gives her peace
of mind it gives you peace of mind one
less thing to think about as we deal
with really important things and money's
not on that list right so right then as
far as the rest of it goes is I'm going
to live like I'm going to live
and so I'm going to keep working four
five and six
simple
you know keep working four five and six
get you know keep putting money away for
retirement she can use that if you don't
make it you can use it if you do make it
um I'll put keep putting money away baby
step five for kids college they gonna
need that uh maybe step six I'm gonna
get the house paid off the closer I get
it paid off the better off I'm gonna be
if I stay and better off she's gonna be
if I don't and so on right and so you
know you get you get real tactical and
real detail but these this plan works
uh whether you whether you're here 10
years or whether you're here 40 years so
it's the best one I got and I would just
keep working it exactly that way you may
have a different level of intensity
and you may have a different level going
to enjoyment
uh uh enjoying some moments here and
there of money that other people might
not uh but none of that's bad that
that's all part of the ride and and the
thing that you're on
um John what am I missing
I think just making it tactile so when
Dave talks about relationships I want
you to get two or three men that will
commit to having coffee or breakfast or
whatever for you with you for the next
10 years
like y'all gonna be my gang and those
are gonna be the guys that you text and
those random nights that you can't sleep
and you're spinning at 3am and those are
the guys they're gonna show up and make
sure if you if you know if you have a
bad day they're gonna be those guys that
show up but you're going to want to
spend every spare second doing these
things that you quote-unquote think you
need to do and one of the things that's
going to be a great gift to your kids is
seeing their old man have friends
seeing their dad have friends seeing
their dad have commitments
um because let's play this out let's say
worst case scenario you got 10 years
then you got a 13 year old an 11 year
old who got a ringside seat of watching
dad be courageous be brave and have
friends and invite men over into his
life right so that's relationships
making sure you and your wife are
together and this comes from Renee Brown
I just think the way she says it is so
is so poignant
be weary of dress rehearsing tragedy you
think you can plan for the back end of
this and you really oh the emotional
back into this you can't
you can't right and so you can't
rehearse her but you can prepare by
laying foundations that's right so what
Dave said about financial about
relationship all that is exactly right
and then go live your best life with
those kids uh man hey Jared go live it
before we go into this commercial
promise me that you or your wife one
will call us back and let us know how
you're doing
now I want to keep I want to keep up
with you and I want to know your story
and I want to know if we can help her
and or you
yeah yeah I'll let you know and and I'll
I'll tell you Dave
um God's kind of been sitting on my
heart with this whole thing and I want
to let your your audience know we we got
a life insurance policy about a month
before we got the diagnosis before any
there we go evidence or knowledge that
there was anything going on you know I
felt fine but on my heart I thought hey
I need to get this set up so so it's
it's you know that much as well uh that
that's one big serious man Wow way to go
way to go
[Music]
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsay we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us America Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality is my co-host
today Kenny's in Portland Maine hi Kenny
how are you
I'm doing well uh Dave and John a quick
question for you baby step two should I
cancel or stop contributing to my HSA
yes
okay
the reason is is that you have a
thousand dollar emergency fund you've
already have money in the HSA how much
do you have in there now
well I keep it minimal I just I keep
spending it as soon as I get it just to
keep to keep paying on the bit on
oh okay if you're using it back out for
medical bills we'll use it as a method
for paying them and let the government
pay a third of your medical bills
because it's tax deductible money going
in and then you pay the medical bill
with it if you can do that yeah we'll
cycle it through there but as far as
building up a big chunk of savings in an
HSA while you're working baby step two I
would not no I usually dwindle it right
down as soon as soon as I get money in
it so I can just get a bit of back well
about the one to lay down you're paying
bills you would have paid otherwise with
tax deductible money so that's that's
going to be smart by 30 cents on the
dollar 25 cents on the dollar
okay so my next question to you is if
I'm putting 200 a paycheck period to get
my medical bills paid off faster should
I increase that contribution
are the medical bills in the baby where
you are in the debt snowball
yes so they're they're at the top of the
debt snowball right now yeah they're one
of the top ones yeah the truck as much
as you can put in there and run it back
through that account because it's just a
method of paying so in other words if
you put a thousand dollars in there you
do not pay taxes on that one thousand
dollars and you use that tax free money
to pay your medical bill with that saves
you about 250 bucks per thousand
okay in taxes so you because you're
running it through there but all we're
doing is using this as a method of
clearing the debt snowball
okay not as a method of building up
savings
awesome I appreciate your time so well
done good good move excellent excellent
I'll tell you another place that applies
folks out there is um if you've got a
chronic
situation
um where there's a ongoing allergies
there's ongoing Crohn's diseases there's
ongoing whatever where you've got these
constant medical bills that are part of
your budget then run those through your
HSA
if you've got an HSA because you can pay
medical bills out of HSA tax-free and so
you know you are going to dump money in
there but if you're just using your HSA
like I have George W put this in place
back in the day and
um that's when it came into being was
under the George W Bush Administration I
started putting as much money as was
allowed into an HSA at that point knock
on wood the Ramsey family's been pretty
healthy and we pretty much can we have
cash flowed any medical that was out of
pocket
so I've never touched my HSA and it's
now in mutual funds and it's hundreds of
thousands of dollars because I've been
doing it for decades now so it's became
another investment vehicle is where it
amounted to but I don't suggest that
kind of thing while you're in baby step
two baby step two is Bill Pay time we're
paying bills we're clearing debt all
that kind of junk John's in Ventura
California hi John how are you
uh honored to speak to you and your
listeners thank you how are you guys
better than we deserve sir how can we
help
yeah so it's been quite a year last
August I got married to the love of my
life and a week after we came back from
the honeymoon my dad fell in his in his
assisted living home and broke his hip
and that led to a series of declining
health events for him and then he passed
away a month later I'm sorry yeah he
spent 25 years in assisted living after
suffering a stroke when I was 13. and
his sister my aunt was his conservator
she did an amazing job with the
conservatorship and the Guardianship and
when my grandpa was alive he had set up
a medical needs trust for my dad and
that trust grew to 175 thousand dollars
um this trust was never used it was
supposed to be our medical needs trust
for any additional things my dad needed
and my aunt formed me on the beneficiary
of the entire trust so fast forward my
wife and I got a check for 150 000 this
week and we're getting the other 25s
maybe in about a month when she finishes
up the final accounting just some of the
little
um you know things with clothes up the
conservatorship so my question to you
guys you know at this stage for my wife
and I are baby step three B and four
would you use all of this as a down
payment or should we set some of this
aside for our investments we're just
we're a little lost as to what to do
with this amount of money yeah
so this comes through as an estate as an
inherited item it's not taxable correct
have you looked into that
my accountant told me and my dad was my
dad
fornia and my accountant said that it's
an inherited trust it was a third party
trust my grandpa has it's not it's not
it's not no matter which state he's in
because it's not a state issue it's a
federal issue
so I I don't think you're taxed at all I
think I agree with your accountant but
your accountant's probably smarter than
I am on this subject so uh I'll go with
him so no taxes have to be withheld so
you're going to clear 175. wow what a
story yeah and you're thinking about
buying a house how much of a house we're
going to buy in Ventura California
well we're actually more like outside of
La
um my wife and I have about a hundred
thousand already saved up in cash we got
275 how much are you going to spend on a
house
you know for our first property 600 to
700 like a condo or something because
homes are like 8.50 and that'll put us
over the 15-year fixed that you
recommend what's your household income
20 000. yeah yeah well I'm gonna make
sure I have an emergency fund in place
and no debt do you already have that not
counting this
yeah we're totally debt free you have an
emergency fund
inside about 30k okay all right now I'm
putting the whole thing down on the
house 100 wow 275 yeah and let's reverse
Engineers so that you understand how
quickly I can make that decision after
doing this all these years number one
I've answered the question two thousand
times but
um number two uh
if you had a condo that was worth 600
and you owed uh
300 on it would you go borrow another
hundred to put it into Investments no
for sure not it's the same thing by not
putting that hundred down
and instead putting it into Investments
if you didn't put the whole thing down
and you put some of it into Investments
it has the same net effect as if you
borrowed on the condo because you
effectually are you're borrowing more on
the condo
so you're borrowing money on your condo
to put it into Investments and I
wouldn't do that that's silly so no no
no we're gonna get the condo down and
then we're gonna get it paid off and you
got a great household income and man
what a Year y'all have been through ups
and downs and crazy up yeah up we get
married down dad Falls dad passes away
up we get 175 man lots of roller coaster
so John I'm gonna ask Dave a question on
that I have about your situation but
don't ask his expertise okay
sure so Dave
there's something in my guts that would
want to sit down and at least put
something on the table make some sort of
gift or a something of appreciation to
my aunt
who's done such an amazing job is that
was she paid
yes um she was and
um yes but she you're right I mean she
did an amazing job and my parents were
actually divorcing when my dad had the
stroke and as a result it led to a lot
of years of I just didn't get to know my
aunt very well I had a great
relationship with my dad
um and now I've been getting to know my
aunt and it's been awesome we've come
together through this and I've been able
to get to know her she's not my wife
if she was paid very very well then I
would buy a nice token gift
if she wasn't paid very very well I
would write a nice check I'm with John
I like that I really like that idea
that's just a relationship thing that's
just a me doing something that makes me
like me
right or it's one of those moments like
Dave and I take so many calls on this
exact situation that goes horribly awry
and there's cousins fighting cousins
suing each other and you had one
gangster sister aunt
who said not on my watch and because of
her diligence and a grandpa and Grandpa
that's right Dad well yeah I mean Dad
says everybody all the players in this
are positive on your day this never
happens in our world man this is so
amazing
um but I I I I would feel in my spirit I
want to do something nice and that that
could that could be a thousand bucks
like who knows what that is there's not
a number on that she wants to go on a
nice cruise and it's 5K write a check
something like that I'd do that for sure
I'm with John that's a good thought John
man that's special good for you brother
yeah that's it's it's unusual and so
it's super special yeah it's good people
doing good things and taking care of
their family wow this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today Proverbs 15 16
better is a little with the fear of the
Lord than great treasure and trouble
with it
Dr Jordan Peterson says perhaps you are
overvaluing what you don't have and
undervaluing what you do
well perhaps contentment is a good thing
I agree with a good doctor Perhaps
Perhaps
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five Ashley is with us
Ashley is in St Louis hi Ashley welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave thank you for taking my call I
feel so so blessed and I'm sure I'm
making my stepdad jealous right now he's
obsessed with you well we're honored how
can we help
well Dave I've gotten myself in a pickle
and I need to figure out if I should
trade in my car and basically get a
junker
tell us more
sounds ominous I shouldn't it is kind of
what you do what kind of car did you
over buy I do Richard uh yeah
um I shouldn't have done it but back in
November I traded in my Honda Accord and
I got a Subaru ascent
and
that means what you got rid of the car
you got rid of a car that was worth what
and you bought a car that you owe how
much on
yeah
yeah that I had was I only owe 7 500 on
and I traded it in for a car to owe 22
000.
German as you roll that 75 on top of
that no say yeah no she had equity in it
the uh I guess you you owed the car was
worth more than 7 500 that you traded
right
yes okay and so what do you make a year
I make about 42 000. okay well twenty
two thousand dollar car doesn't fit that
does it
no it sure doesn't so what are you gonna
do
well I've been contemplating the idea of
trading in for something much less the
problem is
reliability versus Honey a 7 500 Accord
will go to the moon and back solo
Corolla and a Camry
you had a really reliable car
I did I mean that's a Jesus card and a
car and they were all in one Accord I
mean yeah I mean seriously
yes I messed up right but it happens hey
why are you still beating yourself up so
much well you shouldn't got rid of the
car yet so we gotta we got to keep
beating ourselves up till we get rid of
the car so and the car is real nice huh
yeah that Subaru is nice yeah
yeah well it didn't bring you as much
joy as it brought you pain
how has it been a pain well honestly
yeah uh the transmission went out within
the first two weeks of owning it well
that was under warranty I hope
it was covered under a recall yeah yeah
so that was lucky so it was a pain but
it didn't cost so what's wrong with
selling it and getting a 7 500 Civic or
wrong cord
I am just having a really hard time
finding anything reliable it's you drove
a 7 500 car that was reliable
this is mythology
yep you can find a 7 500 you can undo
this
and you'll lose some money but get back
to close to where you were
and have a reliable car that I'm telling
you a ten thousand dollar a seventy five
hundred dollar
Accord it that cars they'll drive 500
000 miles I mean they you can't kill
them
yeah it's just finding that again is my
issue right now because I really yeah
well it would require looking
oh I've been looking I'm obsessed no
you're not
well is there not a car that carvana
won't just drop off at your front door
well the carvana ones you can't seem to
really find a deal on there we go see
you're going to have an excuse for
anything we put on the table so actually
you do whatever you want to do kiddo if
I woke up in your shoes I would say last
November my brain wasn't functioning and
today my brain is functioning and I'm
going to undo the stupid that I did and
go back to the last time that my life
made sense and restart
and both Dave and I have had that exact
conversation with ourselves multiple
times probably this week but yeah it's
hard to be in the garage only Monday but
yeah been there twice yeah and so it's
just you you have to go back to the last
time things made sense
so the psalmist says the Earth or the
psalmist says the blessings of the Lord
have no sorrow
added to them
so as a person of faith I can tell you
God did not give you that car
and the way I know that is there was
sorrow added to it
ding ding
exit the devil car get the Jesus card
oh jeez
there you go Reddit there's some fodder
well it was a joke
you're going to be trying to tell you I
can tell you that sometimes as a person
of Faith you think you're doing what
you're supposed to be doing what God's
telling you to do and you find out later
it was last night's Pizza not the Holy
Spirit and you look back and you go the
blessings of the Lord have no sorrow
added to them and a sorrow added to this
so apparently I missed that one
I can't I mean like how many bazillion
times in 62 years I've done that a bunch
but I can go right back to the last time
there was peace and go I'm going back to
the Accord it's then it's like it's like
when you're playing a video game and you
die and you go back to the start of the
other level just go back there start
there except you don't have to die
I mean the part of her that thought this
was a good idea that probably needs to
be done and then she can go back
[Music]
actually you got the worst possible
series of answers on this call of
anybody in the last 20 years on the show
sell the car we got the Devil Car the
death in the video game all of it's
lumped into one bad call so I'm just
saying this is this Kyle get us the Lord
out of this call how can we help Colin
San Diego right quick before we run out
of time
oh awesome Dave thank you so much for
taking my call I'm a huge fan of you as
a leader in finance and a spiritual
leader as well so you're very kind
before we run out of time what's your
question
yeah so I live in San Diego and um I
have a two-year-old daughter and my wife
we live in a very small uh thousand
square foot condo here in San Diego and
uh we bought it about six years ago
um and we bought it for like 250 it's
currently valued at like 5 30. what's
your question Kyle
well my question is should we leave
California with my wife being pregnant
and we have another baby on the way
we're considering if we should we we
need a bigger your motivation for
leaving is what
well to get it more more inexpensive
housing you live in a very expensive
area and you want a better you want a
less expensive housing market
yeah but why would you this is where it
gets complicated is when I tell my wife
hey we need to move we have 300 000
equity and frankly we can come up with
another 50 Grand and just buy a house
350 cash somewhere else yeah my wife
says well my family is here I love my
family and I can't leave them and her
family actually said well if you guys
stay here we'll give you guys 75 to 100
000 to help you buy a house the problem
is problems here cost nine hundred
thousand dollars so even with a hundred
thousand dollars cash on top of our 300
Equity hey brother just completely price
Kyle this is not a a house question yet
this is a marriage question
this is about a guy who's looking at a
house as an investment vehicle and a
wife who wants to create a home or under
family and that this is a conversation
to be solved over breakfast first take
your father-in-law to breakfast and get
them to move with you yeah this isn't a
math problem just yet this is a young
married couple
trying to see which is the best path and
she has a different vision of what this
looks like you have a different picture
of what this looks like and you only
need to align those pictures man
personal finance is personal in the
sense that it affects your family and so
where you live in conjunction with your
wife and her family does matter that's a
valid part of the equation now how to
make that affordable in San Diego that's
hard math right there that's tough hey
thank you for calling I wish we had a
magic answer for you but we don't that
puts us out of the Ramsey Show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]